for anyone who's watched zonkey no
terror there's this one scene in episode
4 where these cops are trying to solve
this riddle to stop this terrorist plot
and you know it's a serious threat we're
all wondering whether they're going to
be able to figure this out they're
having this you know
very serious conversation then out of
nowhere
we're greeted with the shot of the most
aesthetic looking bowl of ramen
i've ever seen it was like if kate upton
emma watson and scarlett johansson
had a threesome and that threesome
was this bowl of ramen that's the kind
of sex appeal we're talking about i
i [ __ ] fell in love and that was it
it lasted for like two seconds then
right after we go back to this terrorist
plot i couldn't give a [ __ ] about now
because how can anything
top this exquisite luscious crowning
jewel of
noodle soup so here i am still thinking
about it years later so
i i guess we're going to make a video
about food and anime food in anime is
just this peculiar thing i've noticed
because it
hardly ever looks bad like not saying
real food can't look sexy as [ __ ] either
but you can take the most mundane of
dishes in the real world
transported to the anime world and it
would be like at least an eight out of
ten would bang
i mean [ __ ] if there was an easter card
show where a ham sandwich was the main
character you'd have the scene where
it's this skinny malnourished single
slice not even buttered sandwich in the
real world then it's transported to the
anime world and suddenly it's the
[ __ ] bee's knees of ham sandwiches
you know
thick slices of honey smoked premium ham
with crisp
iceberg lettuce sweet refreshing
tomatoes in between
freshly baked gourmet multi-grain bread
the six-inch subway syndrae takes a look
and falls in love it has its harem potty
following it
everywhere even the little sister tuna
sandwich is just like what is
key
i i had no idea where i was going with
that analogy let's start with the
obvious topic
food anime if you want some quick cheap
down and dirty good old-fashioned food
porn there are plenty
there are plenty of anime to choose from
you want food anime there's like one
every season for all the cuisines you
could ever think of you want to see
amazing non-existent food be described
to you you watch toroko you want to see
a girl who loves ramen noodles well
how about koizumi-san loves ramen
noodles you want to watch
food that makes girls realize their hips
are moving on their own
you watch hentai like any normal person
but here you get exactly what it says on
the tin
you watch food anime because you want to
see food [ __ ] chukka i know and on
the gordon ramsay approved scale
something like shokugeki is the sword
arted line of basic
entry-level anime food appreciation you
know this dish has been tossed around so
much
even your mum's had a go speaking of
which love or hate sao here's a prime
example of an average show which for
whatever reason has delicious looking
food i mean
bang on arsenal all you want but she
knew that to be the winning girl
she needed to max out her
sandwich-making skill tree
as every woman should and that leads
nicely to what i really want to talk
about
food in non-food anime food looks good
in anime regardless of the focus and
this is what gets me
where the food isn't even the main focus
but it's just
cocking us by being there the biggest
offenders that come to mind
are makoto shinkai's works and ghibli
films shingai is already well known for
his skill of being able to make scenes
that look more aesthetic than life and
his food is no exception
this omelet looks more attractive than i
ever will
and i'm not even mad but it's not just
in the final products
it's in the preparation as well i've
never seen someone who so perfectly
mastered the art of animating foods
being cut because in most anime they try
to show the skill of the chef by having
them cut things as fast as possible like
but in shinkai stuff it's so clean crisp
and precise and it's
just [ __ ] mesmerizing like let's make
these scenes the new 24 7 lo-fi hip-hop
beat streams and maybe these poor anime
girls can finally finish their homework
but ghibli are the king of having
memorable food scenes that stick in our
minds even though the films have nothing
to do with food
we all saw the buffet scene and spirited
away and thought yeah you know what if
that [ __ ] was in front of me i'd
probably turn into a pig too
and it'd be totally worth it the
breakfast seat
the breakfast scene from how's moving
castle look at these clean eggs look at
this
thick bacon tell me how this isn't its
own asmr experience
these are what always stick with me
because unlike with food anime you're
just not expecting it
plus sometimes food anime just
exaggerates things a bit too much that i
can't relate to it anymore you know i
can't ever say my clothes have ever been
blown off when having a good meal and if
someone started
coming every time we get some nuggets at
mackie d's i'd probably think
they were a bit weird this though these
scenes in non-food-related anime
the tears of joy you have when you have
that perfect meal
this is the real [ __ ] this is the stuff
i relate to
this is a fat kebab at 3am after a night
out with the lads
this is an extra large cheese-crusted
papa john's
after having won too many brownies in
amsterdam
this is
[Music]
umami the next thing i want to touch on
is these times when i'd see a dish in an
anime and i'd have an incredible craving
to try it even
if i'd never heard of it before and
don't lie i know you have as well i
think the scene that sticks out to me as
it's the first time it happened was from
great teacher onizuka there's a scene
where they're just eating sushi and
somehow in this ugly ass
looking show the sushi still looks
bloody exquisite now in the scene
they're bigging up this fatty tuna and
the 15 year old uncultured didn't even
like sushi at the time gigguk had never
heard of fatty tuna before so i start
playing all these tuna related questions
in my head what the hell is fatty tuna
did they force feed this tuna or
something do they have morbidly obese
tuna
kind of chubby tuna body positive tuna
i don't [ __ ] know but right then i
said to myself that i need to try this
sometime in my life
and that started my journey of wanting
to eat dishes just because it was in an
anime
you got your marble tofus from angel
beets pork bowl cutlets from yurio nice
ramen so much bloody ramen everywhere
and whenever you see it there's always
that scene where they lift the noodles
up and it's just
hanging on the chopsticks and you're
just like calm down boner
it's not real then we have the food
we're all familiar with you have your
pizzas
your burgers now that's a tasty burger
you like sugary sweets well
here are all the sugary sweets you could
ever hope for not sweet enough
well here's an adorable maid lolly
eating sugary sweets is that sweet
enough
oh you have diabetes now [ __ ] you i also
want to dedicate a quick section on
how perfect bento boxes always look i
mean some of this stuff
is like a bloody art form but maybe i'm
just salty at how bento boxes in real
life
are infinitely superior to any lunch
boxes i got as a kid and here anime
lunches up with its 17 course three
layer gourmet meal
box because every anime girl turns into
gordon ramsay when cooking lunches
and don't get me started on their school
dinners i mean
look at this this dinner is more stacked
than elon musk's bank account
did you do this jamie oliver finally i
wanted to dedicate a section about
eggs i'd avoid the different dishes and
ingredients to be portrayed in anime
eggs for some reason get the most
premier treatment i mean
it's an egg it's just one of the most
basic ingredients
oh son of a but i never looked at it
like it's this
sexy ingredient until i watched anime
watching eggs in anime is like one of
the most erotic experiences you can have
we normally associate jiggle physics
with breasts and you know sometimes they
can malfunction but with eggs it's
always 100 spot on fried eggs almoy rice
even raw eggs somehow look appetizing
and no matter how hard you try to
recreate it it just looks awful
[Music]
it's umami [ __ ] if anime eggs had an
instagram it'd probably have more
followers than me
which wouldn't be that hard actually
follow me on instagram at gigerkz
overall food and anime is just one of
those small insignificant things that's
actually affected me and caused me to
seek something out
there are a lot of dishes i never would
have tried or even have wanted to try if
i never saw them in an anime and
if that makes me an easily
impressionable weeb [ __ ] well
blame anime for making them always look
so damn delicious
and maybe not everyone's as passionate
about food and anime as i am
but you know what there's one thing i
wanted to say
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month too
lee watts matey malabadan big black hawk
elephant
robert hanborg k must live and everyone
else on patreon for helping to support
me for this month and making this video
possible
i know it's been a few weeks since my
last upload and it's kind of because
i was going through a bit of writer's
block i'll be honest nothing i did
satisfy me so i thought
[ __ ] it why not do something stupid with
this video so yeah i hope you like the
final product
hopefully i'm back to my normal self now
though so until then
i've been gig and i will see you all
next time